this plane bought Taiwanese evacuees
home from a quarantined cruise ship in
Japan hit by the coronavirus while their
plane and/or luggage gets a thorough
disinfection the evacuees will be
isolated for another two weeks these
precautions are the new normal in the
fight to contain the coronavirus in
Italy top officials meet after the virus
claimed its first victim in the country
an elderly man in northern Italy died
after being hospitalized the number of
cases spiked to 17 in just one day in
Kedah new a town southeast of Milan
officials shut down schools and
businesses issued an official order to
close down all the shops and we're
following the order so we're closing
there's a lot of alarm and that also
worries me a percentage miroku Costanzo
we are old and very concerned I am 76
years old I live on my own I really
don't know what to do public events are
banned and that includes church services
the first patient to contract the virus
here had met a friend who had recently
traveled to China but the World Health
Organization is worried about another
trend they have spotted in the latest
infections although the total number of
cases outside China remains relatively
small we are concerned about the number
of cases with no clear epidemiological
link such as travel history to China or
contact with a confirmed case in Ukraine
local residents blocked buses with
passengers evacuated from China these
scenes prompted president zalenski to
give his fellow citizens are dressing
down on television these are our
Ukrainians they're not sick with plague
they don't have horns and hooves they
are ordinary normal people he promised
that
the organizers of the blockade would be
prosecuted authorities are working to
contain the fear of the virus as well as
its spread for more I'm joined by
virologist Martin stürmer in Frankfurt
Professor Schlemmer thanks for joining
me the director general of the w-h-o as
we just heard in that report has said
they're concerned about some new cases
that may not have a link to China a
second person has just died Line Italy
how worried should we be we should be
worried about this case it's because it
makes they make it more difficult to
control the spread of the virus um the
reason is they do not fit into our case
definition and therefore they might not
be tested or maybe tested delayed so
they can spread the virus in an
uncontrolled way the whu-oh has also
warned that the window of opportunity to
contain this epidemic is closing what
your governments around the world be
doing yeah we heard about Italy so they
do quite restrictive measures and that
might be one one way to be alarmed of we
are in control of the virus for the
spread of the virus and even be more
careful in looking into the traffic from
and to China and then making people
coming from China making them more aware
to look at themselves to do not go out
and go to a festival or somewhere else
and if I come back from China please
stay at home for 40 days and be sure
that you do not get ill and and carry
the virus somewhere else and what about
in China I mean are there signs at the
outbreak there has peaked just looking
at the numbers they reported it might be
however they've changed their case
definition three times in eight days so
it's very difficult to realize this is a
true numbers of people carrying the
virus so I'm not sure whether this is a
peak is there a vaccination for this
virus within reach they are working on
it but I would expect at least in June
to July and and even then it has to be
tested in a smaller more facia
before you can use it widely so it's
difficult I would not expect it in the
next next weeks or month right and how
likely then is it that this epidemic is
going to be labeled a pandemic and it
depends on how the situation in Italy
might might change actually we heard
about 17 cases if they do not are not
able to control the spread of the virus
then we have the definition for pandemic
monster my speaking to us from Frankfurt
thanks very much for the update you're
welcome